good morning believe nation great to be
with you again today happy with day is
today happy Thursday welcome to
gratitude journal live stream number 44
we do this every day I'm still sick we
do this every day every weekday at least
I do it every day but we broadcast every
weekday thinking about three things
we're grateful for if you look at
happiness and you want to be happy all
the happiness studies talk about
gratitude as being a key component to it
I think we need happy grateful
entrepreneurs go out there and have a
big impact on the world so we list three
things and we're grateful for I'll do
mine you guys are year to the live chat
but those you watch it afterwards leave
it below and also as you go through and
think about why just spend an extra
couple seconds thinking about why your
people for each of those things don't
make a big difference on that and the
emotional by like that you'll get from
it so I'm going to start off mm-hmm I'm
grateful number wider get before Kleenex
last night was a rough night I went to
bed early enough just woke up a number
of times with the runny nose and super
grateful for the availability of kleenex
to solve solve runny nose issues
otherwise I don't know what we'd be
using can't imagine all that coming out
on a sleeve or something to be pretty
nasty so I'm very grateful for that
people who ever invented Kleenex mm-hmm
I love you guys um number 2 i'm gonna
i'm gonna shout out to members of my
team sandra and monsewer i don't think i
mentioned before on the channel i may
have there behind the scene sandra is my
personal assistant and she books all of
my meetings which has been super helpful
she she will uh you know book all of my
interviews all of my google hangouts all
of my phone calls all of my coffee
meetings and balances my schedule so
that just automat
he works I was doing it myself for a
while and then get her eyes actually
came up with a program for people to
book their own times in which worked
great for a while but I'm super grateful
for her to be able to manage all that
for me so I just have to show up and
look at my calendar and just go and
everything's kind of been taken care of
so frees up a lot of my time and
frustration and then manzoor does a lot
of both Sandra by the way is also shine
in the comments if you're on the main
channel you see shine that Sandra so
when she's not booked in my meeting
she's hanging out in the comments
answering you guys monsewer does a lot
of the posting to Facebook and Twitter
for me the different quotes that were
putting up but in the context here one
thing is really helped me with in this
channel is moving the videos so he'll
move the video from this channel to the
other chain up with the thumbnail on it
and when we do the league of legends
live stream he'll put the thumbnail on
that and name it and put in the
description and all that stuff and so
again just super helpful that at the
start always doing everything myself and
I didn't know how long it would continue
and I this is kind of a typical process
for me at the start of anything i'll
usually do everything myself or almost
everything myself the test did to try to
see if I like it see if I want to
continue so with the gratitude live
stream with league of legends live
stream at the beginning I was doing
everything for the first 30 days it was
me doing everything the artwork the
thumbnails they upload in the
description the titling the hosting you
know all of that just to kind of figure
out do I want this am I going to
continue on this thing or not is it
going to be worth the time and
investment to keep going with it or not
and then we decided yeah we're going to
keep doing it for a bit it's okay that's
gonna be too much work so I need to
delegate some of the tasks away that
don't need me to do it so I'm still on
camera with you guys but everything else
kind of gets passed off to my team
behind the scenes so I'll be focused on
other stuff so super grateful the Sandra
Mansour for the help
and then number 3 i'm grateful for our
meet before attention to detail i'm i'm
heading out right after this we don't
have a league of legends live stream
until tomorrow I've got to go back
downtown and do a few pickups for the
audiobook and that's usually where there
was a little bit of a puff on the
microphone or you know I you hear me
flipping pages or something just to
really tiny things and so I've got a
rush at nine ten they go down there and
do that but I appreciate them their
attention to detail I'm making sure that
we have our super high quality audio
product you know I'm doing my best to go
and I'm gonna have to really have some
tea or something forward I'm doing my
best to really bring the quality and in
what I can do orite in speaking and
reading and delivering some passion and
excitement on that audio version of the
book but I'm relying on them to take
care of the other stuff like the
technical stuff the recording you know
all of that stuff and every time I
further back it sounds so amazingly
clear it's I'm blown away but I'm really
grateful that they are so a tent they
have such a focus on the other details
to make sure that we're getting a really
high quality product I find for myself
sometimes a very detail-oriented and
sometimes I'm not so I know J reyez is
probably in the live chat is work with
me in a couple projects and if
something's like two pixels off I'm
going to notice I'm going to want to
change it so super attention to detail
but other times ok aren't that's good
enough let's put it out so anyway
feeling grateful for attention to detail
this morning alright we've got a couple
minutes let's go to the live chats who
you guys have for me today best you
probe leading us off best you pro league
miss off that's new i like it good
morning believe nation got lots we good
before today best you pro is grateful
for one completing the 30 day list
building challenge or best you pro
website congratulations to four
challenges and for the brilliant team
that helps to solve them ealing it and
34 life it is truly wonderful 11 that's
a good good morning from jamaica 11
relaxing sleep
number one grateful for waking up early
today feeling refreshed after a good
night's sleep I wish I could say the
same to a grateful for my renewed
commitment to a healthy lifestyle that
involves creating opportunities for fun
and exercise cool & 3 i'm grateful for
the opportunity to go for a walk with my
girlfriend this morning even though the
weather is starting to get cold very
cool I like it I I walked Nina to the
car this morning but that didn't have to
go outside mmm what else we got Zeno's
in the house a question at Zeno after
your video today for Evan in the top
we've been having and then the answer
haven't gave the other day made me think
I really want to do something for Evan
too that's awesome really appreciate
that yeah if you guys haven't seen Xena
made a video surprise video that he put
up on his channel and I decided to host
it on my channel as well so you guys can
go check it out on either of our
channels really appreciate that Zeno
feeling the love man uh I don't have a
social media presence but hey I can make
a video yeah I appreciate it I'd love to
see it I appreciate all the love guys I
appreciate all the love best you Pro we
consider Evan Carmichael one of the
greatest positive influences here so we
like to share his videos on Twitter and
stuff like that but a personal thank you
video would be nice always always I'm
feeling the love this morning guys i
love it that was actually where we
started to build our brand just over six
months ago we would be happy to help out
a friend from the believe nation cool
zeno grateful for bitter number one
cognitive behavioral therapy i'm about
to start the hopefully better the way I
think interesting you wouldn't say by
reading my comments but my thoughts are
mostly negative with depression
hopefully we can the throats crazy
hopefully we can be a part of your
journey out of that say no because yeah
you've left a really positive
a lot of people here to the continuous
positivity love and support from believe
nation which has already helped brighten
up my days a lot 11 3 the gratitude live
streams have helped me to realize there
are a lot of little things that can be
happy about I always appreciate what
Zeno rights and I mean I appreciate
everybody raise but if he sure was in
our rights i still remember the clouds
the clouds that make us was it the
clouds that make a normal boring
repetitive seen different and
interesting i like that when i when i
see the clouds 80 i think a human gerrae
is taken for hugs which can be so
soothing for the plant Nina gave me
which brings balance and harmony to my
environment so the Nina like to do is
give plants for believe nation who
contribute so much i love that what else
we got tons of comments Mitchell okay
but for one friends too also with Zino
I'm having the livestream to start off
my day great 3 the book i started
reading about the future people get
ready by Robert W McChesney and John
Nichols very cool haven't heard of that
book but thank you for sharing then Jen
I'm grateful for movies I love going to
the theater and getting popcorn and join
the story in full blown picture my first
job was working at movie theater boo boo
I love that and Sarah today I'm grateful
for this day and moment grateful for new
experience experimentations grew before
the internet and social media made the
world smaller and more accessible I love
it guys I gotta go 910 I gotta go do my
audiobook uh they're supposed to be two
other live streams today I'm enough i'm
going to do them depends how i feel i've
got two other phone calls and i have a
meeting tonight it's going to go to like
eleven o'clock so pretty nutso day but
uh we'll see i may see you guys later on
today if not i will see you tomorrow
morning have an amazing day I believe in
you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you soon